aujourd'hui nous partons à la rencontre
de Janine cette maman a bénéficié du
dispositif appelé accompagnement des
malades il mesure mise en place par le
département pour permettre à
l'accompagnant de malade devant subir
des soins en métropole d'être soutenu
dans cette démarche financièrement
matériellement et humainement
à la Réunion quand un point chez malade
il doit parfois aller subir des soins en
métropole le département permet aux
accompagnants de malade de bénéficier
d'un soutien matériel financier et
humains à travers la prise en charge du
billet d'avion la mise en place d'un
numéro vert une aide ponctuelle de 500
euros maximum en fonction des besoins et
l'attribution d'un parc d'accueil
bonjour Eugénie
ou la bénéficie de l'aide
l'accompagnement des malades
expliquez-nous comment la fonctionné
pourquoi le besoin de cette aide et
quels sont les aides qu'on a eu mais en
fait quand on a découvert sa maladie il
fallait aller à la métropole dans les
médias on savait pas grand chose c'était
de notre première fois qu'on partait le
département a mis à disposition madame
zit et nous a beaucoup aidés elle nous a
beaucoup soutenu après son papa a pu
venir grâce au département
à Paris mais en fait quand on est là-bas
on est tout du coup il faut qu'on aille
soutien aussi et moralement physiquement
c'est bien parce que si on est tout seul
on est perdu merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup merci
c'est la fille de génie a pu être
accompagnée par sa maman et son papa
c'est grâce notamment au dispositif
accompagnement des malades proposés par
le département de La Réunion un soutien
moral financier et logistique
indispensable madame zit référence du
pôle social à Paris et présente sur
place afin d'être au plus près des
familles en cas de besoin et les aider
dans leur démarche bonjour Marie bonjour
Amélie Marie comment fonctionne ce
dispositif et qui peut en bénéficier
alors le dispositif d'accompagnement des
malades est un dispositif qui a mis en
place par le département pour permettre
aux usagers d'accompagner un proche en
métropole ça peut être un parent une
personne de confiance parce qu'on
éloigne chez nous ils sont loin de chez
eux donc pourquoi c'est important
d'avoir une antenne du département de la
réunion à Paris
c'est important pour moi c'est un point
d'ancrage c'est un point c'est comment
dire une ressource et puis les gens
peuvent venir discuter aussi avec nous
échanger c'est important nous on n'a pas
forcément toutes les solutions mais on
peut les accompagner merci Marie
[Musique]
grâce à ce dispositif mis en place
depuis 2011 Cette année plus de 100
personnes ont été aidées par le
département afin d'accompagner leurs
proches en métropole par un budget total
de plus de 200000 euros un budget
conséquent mais important pour le
département qui souhaite être présent
auprès des familles réunionnaises dans
ces moments difficiles afin de permettre
aux malades de bénéficier du soutien
dans l'accompagnant bonjour Julie
que ce qui reste du long terme et donc
du coup il y a de nouveaux dispositifs
qui est mis en place pour permettre aux
familles que là depuis plus de trois
mois une allocation mensuelle c'est bien
c'est une bonne chose que le département
a pu faire ça et ça y est les familles
aussi en fait merci à vous et merci au
département aussi et à les élus aussi
[Musique]
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur les dispositifs
accompagnement des malades n'hésitez pas
vous avez toutes les coordonnées qui
s'affichent en bas de votre écran le
département des générations c'est fini
société on va voir cet épisode ainsi que
les épisodes précédents rendez-vous sur
notre site et nos réseaux sociaux quant
à moi je vous retrouve très vite pour
une nouvelle épisode à bientôt
[Musique]
la semaine prochaine nous allons
découvrir le dispositif Aden Laden est
le départementale à la création
d'entreprise nouvelle une aide destinée
aux personnes en difficulté sociale et
ayant un projet de création d'entreprise
[Musique]